[ Thunder rumbles ]
-Monsters and ghosts
used to cause quite a fright
But in 2019,
there are much scarier sights.
So gather around, kids,
as I tell you a tale
of today's modern terrors.
The first one is kale.
It's everywhere, in everything
And I'll tell you what.
It looks like a leaf,
and it tastes like a butt.
Yes, chewing on kale
will make you cry,
but if you don't eat it,
they say you will die.
♪♪♪♪
I used to be scared of
haunted-house booby traps.
Now I'm scared of white ma
in red baseball caps.
You see them and think,
"Oh, what's he gonna do?
Make America Great Again?
Shit. Great for who?"
Monsters and zombies,
creepy peeping toms
are nothing compared
to Twitter dot com.
Scarier than monsters
who swallow you whole
is the loneliest creature --
the Internet troll.
-[ Muttering angrily ]
-He'll scare you so bad,
pee will run down your leg
His name's filled with numbers
and his face is an egg.
But the biggest horror
sure to drive you insane
is our current leader.
I won't call him by name.
We're all so afraid
of a nuclear attack,
we can no longer sleep,
and we live on Zantac.
More frightening than a vampir
without a reflection?
He's projected to win
the 2020 election!
[ Laughing evilly ]